all right how's it going David going
great how about you are you ready to do
an expedition
yeah well I'm ready to see what it looks
like so this is the government plane
rack expedition from Far Cry New Dawn
the way that this works when you get in
the game is you go and you hit some
outposts you get the resource ethanol
you go back to your base and you unlock
these expeditions their missions that
are basically outside of the main game
in which you kind of just run around and
steal a you run around you steal a
package and you extract so we're gonna
talk you through this one sure give you
some tips and tricks and just generally
try and have a good time by the way I've
got a bunch of gold weapons including my
gold happy shovel what happens if I hit
you with my gold happy shovel give it a
try yep my right through yeah Verena so
once you go here and load up first
any time you land in an expedition you
can actually immediately go over to the
side of the helicopter even if you
didn't pick up the weapon that you
wanted and then you can kit out
so the expeditions come in a couple
different levels and also the crafting
comes in different levels as you can see
in the top my screen here there's a you
know basically grey blue purple and gold
gold being the hardest and you
definitely want to have crafted weapons
that are the equivalent of whatever the
expedition is going to be the first time
around expeditions are actually pretty
easy so it's a good way for you just
learn how they work and then after that
they get tougher and tougher and we're
now at a level three purple expedition
which we'll see because David hasn't
done one before right and elements start
getting randomized here so we'll get
going in just a second
I'm just trying to see my options
clearly I haven't been able to oh I
guess the helicopter just left he just
peaced down on you right already
all right well I'm we're gonna see how
this works out I've got my fists and I
have a rusty flamethrower this is this
is great you know what's funny is I you
picked up that flamethrower on the last
run right so hopefully it will do you
give this time I don't know how much
damage you're gonna do to these enemies
because you have level 1 what
yeah it'll be interesting for sure we
might have to uh I might have to just
kind of stick to the stealth one of the
interesting things about the plane wreck
mission is it's really spread out some
of the other missions are a little bit
more compacted this one you actually
it's important for you to locate where
vehicles are like we know there's one in
the vehicle Bay here is the tailing of
the airplane so I'm gonna start in
typical Far Cry fashion by just looking
around with binoculars for sure try and
figure out what everyone is it looks
like we got a sniper up top
I have no binocular so I'm just gonna
scare all the the Meese away towards the
enemies you are freshly minted new da no
nyan yeah ya know for sure this is my
first century like Indy and the whole
car cries serious oh this is gonna be
really really fun so right now it's a
pretty quiet we're just gonna go in um
you're basically looking for the purple
smoke in the purple smoke lead you to
you should just take this vehicle
because we're gonna need it in a minute
or just take it like right now like nope
oh there's a guy right here
oh he's gold Wow okay ah oh no okay so
normally you want to stealth your way in
I you know luckily I have gold weapons
but since uh since we're new maybe we
can do something snazzy or like let's
throw this man a meat popsicle and see
yeah see what happens no animals seem
interested in the bait come on animals
that's excellent
all right I think I can actually execute
one of these guys yeah grab the truck go
for it I have upgraded to level 3 which
means I can just do the old execution on
level 3 enemies oh there's a gun up here
if you want to climb up here you can
grab a mounted weapon I'm gonna go take
care of the sniper up top for sure and
then we're gonna go locate the package
so whoa you just kind of saw me right
away let me get on this mountain you
know I think the package is up here once
we get the package there's a timer and
that timer basically means they will
start coming at you in waves
by the way you can't kill all of the bad
guys in these missions
it's just not possible oh there's two up
here
each shovel oh you're up there on the
top there's one guy down here I think
he's alerted too you know
okay let me see if I can all right so
we're doing good
we've totally alerted everybody you know
you should start doing work on that
mount again yeah well I'm gonna I'm
gonna roast this guy first I got my
happy shovel and we're gonna go look
flow oh my god that did nothing well yet
I'm gonna climb up on the top over by
the ladder pretty much where all the
fire is you should be able to find I see
the fire I'm [ __ ] nuts I mean I can be
on fire okay so that's the extraction
zone why don't we go take the the nasty
truck hey why don't you grab the nasty
truck and I'm gonna wingsuit off the top
alright it was interesting I don't think
I had the option to get into the truck
but I'm gonna give it another go here
grab that Trek see I'm gonna use I'm
gonna cover you from up top now Oh again
you should be able to get in the truck
yeah trying oh very nice I'm gonna cover
you ten out of ten landing oh there's
people in here let me try and run by
there we go drive vehicle alright I am
in alright the monster truck start
heading out from behind I got my really
sick oh that truck is very trapped
tracks
did they yeah totally booby-trapped it
oh my goodness
I'm gonna come get you then because
actually there's parachute and they
don't stop spawning we just got to get
there right so attempt number one to get
vehicle did not go well there's my
lifeless body I got you there you go
were you just gonna flee on foot or what
oh you're getting shot can you kill
people because um maybe not particularly
well maybe this guy whoa
it's it's a work in progress
hey I'm down oh you're down uh-uh
I got rocketed okay where are you right
now cuz I'm about to die I mean the bush
is on fire okay cool
oh boy this is the place it's still on
fire how do I know okay this is the
purple version I bandaged up yeah I
don't think I have any bandages
unfortunately oh here the rocket
launcher right on top oh my god okay
well I'm healing up a little bit the
fires coming over to me now there's a
fire spread it does it's really cool how
its brandade okay here we go
let's get you know crouched all right
all right now we got a jet out we got
this oh my god there's so many icons
well they don't stop they just keep
coming
yeah you uh nope I got a bike okay here
we go you're nice okay well I'm I'm
actually making some pretty good leeway
on foot so we could wingsuit off the top
of this one which actually is pretty
cool way to do it alright alright let's
have a little race let's see who gets
there first mirror yeah I may have a bit
of a head start I'm coming up on you I
got here is he already there yeah he is
alright let's get that out you have to
dect to the other side of the chopper
possibly yeah yeah if I switch the seats
this is stopping over there there's just
a bunch of highwaymen like gonna haunt
us they're playing like musical chairs
and that is how you do government plane
wreck with a level two oh there's like
oh my god there's a chopper on us can I
switch seats and I badly want to get
that helicopter home man yeah so that's
how you do the government plane wreck
expedition and you get crafting
components which will allow you to craft
some much better gear for the next
run-through alright David so round two
and you know what we just realized what
this plane is out of the Splinter Cell
series no way so we're gonna let you
as in a little secret that we actually
discovered during this session so if you
want to get a Sam Fisher outfit actually
it's in this game so what you do is you
land and you head to the head of the
airplane you go on in will sneak in here
because actually the objective was at
the head of the airplane this time we
got it on the tail a ton of times before
this Oh get them so I'm gonna do oh I'm
about to clear this first but so here's
what you do you walk into this room this
is the main room there's actually notes
everywhere um kind of giving hints about
like Splinter Cell notes
yeah like splinters on this airplane
belongs to and let me see if I can get
this guy to head off in the other
direction yeah I grabbed his attention
so there's a couple goals here if if the
objective is not here this is easy if
the objective is here then this becomes
a lot more difficult a little gold tear
take ah right in the jugular and that's
an ability by the way that you have to
unlock oh where oh oh no no oh no um
well well we're gonna use the hard way
you explode okay
so you go here there's no prompt here
which is really the only tricky part you
can interact with this oh wow and you
send out a a worldwide nuclear threat
alert next you just head off to the
right here and this door opens back here
oh there it is and you grabbed yourself
Wow Smasher Sam Fisher outfit
oh my check it out let's just pause
everything to check out this so here
apparently the the things you can read
on it are really funny - oh cool like
when you actually read the individual
notes there's like there's little notes
we won't spoil it all for you but
there's actually little notes on all of
the gear pieces and and then you become
I'm going to use the the excellent photo
mode here oh we've been having a lot of
fun with the photo mode you become Sam
Fisher
that's really cool it's nice lighting -
yeah she's really cool uh you can't do
facial expressions unfortunately I
wonder why because you're under a mask
that's why so anyway um then you just
have to basically complete this mission
which means it follows all of the other
things that we've been saying in this
guide so far which is basically grab
your snazzy package down here and go
make it to the extract jet out and that
is how you'd become Sam Fisher all right
so let's take it back to our next run
where we we also tried doing the package
again and we're doing a second Walker
what we're gonna test some other aspects
of this game David I'm having deja vu
kind of feel like we've we've been here
well I guess it's part date I'll be
right cuz I mean I'm kind of expecting
some some differences this run so this
is a government plane wreck I'm assuming
this is on the hardest difficulty and
poor poor David it may be maybe there's
a chance he stands a chance I don't
think I can drop weapons so you get
kitted out again yeah I'll have to see
what I can craft which is basically gray
tier weapons if you pick weapons up off
of them though it seems like you get to
keep it
Oh interesting I don't know if they drop
weapons that are that good
we'll find out so we have a completely
different location now we're like we're
definitely not anywhere near the
original crash site Oh interesting so I
think we're gonna go that the head
section of it this time okay
but why don't we make our way around see
if we can find a vehicle or do something
fun like wingsuit off of the top of the
main airplane sure this way now your
wingsuit you just have it equipped or is
that something you had to get yeah it's
a good question it's in your perk tree
it's something you unlock as well as the
GOC the grappling hook those are staples
of farcry and definitely some
thing you're gonna want I would like to
try and kill somebody for you and see if
their weapons are better than your
weapon right which would be really
interesting if that's the case I just
crafted a blue oMG but it won't be
stealthy we got a guy here although he's
kind of piecing out what's he running
away from he's a he's just patrolling ok
my chances of getting him without
alerting everybody are not great but you
know Yolo
let's go get him let's go get that man
patrolling ok oh he's turning around
well it's still my friend oh my god he's
coming back uh ok we got a vehicle now
and we got a dude see what he has I'm
really curious yeah let's pull my hair
okay so Lutz there's a rifle right
hopper um it seems like his is actually
gray and I currently have a blue yeah so
rip me yep okay I got another guy here
so what he has is actually worse yes but
I got a shovel and time to use it maybe
the guy had a grey and that's why he was
on patrol he was the the weakest link
let's do this
you're gonna check the shovel oh my
goodness you've been showing goodness
that's the best part of our cry is
definitely the shovel launching shovel I
don't actually know where that shovel
went and I don't know I should have
tried that I should have seen if you
could have picked up he doesn't have a
weapon I don't think yeah we're in the
unique situation where we're trying to
scavenge oh no he does this right here
is right I kicked them and that looks
pretty good actually a sniper rifle yeah
but it's it's great again it's like
still better than what you had no well I
mean like I said I crafted the the rare
LMG so like its color tears a little
higher well let's go the completely non
stealth you're out you know you can
actually also just run around picking up
resources in this environment which you
always need they're good for crafting
totally all right where did that
motorbike go
back out to that little landing right
there thank you jeez boned oh no no no
it's right here
you drive yeah all right let me in nope
I'm different later I'm just gonna right
here yeah all right take us through the
smoke that's behind us smoke that's
behind us all right very good
let's see here you think I could like
launch off this man I mean why wouldn't
you okay that's uh oh my god are we
stuck you've messed up our plan oh my
plane is messed up we're going on foot
can i oh no that's all right let's do it
on foot
yeah let me give it one last yeah so to
be honest we've actually found you can
run these pretty quickly and we're just
gonna have a bit of fun on our own it's
not like I met it I met gold tier right
now so these are fairly straightforward
missions although I'm curious there's
other ones we can't talk about just yet
but I'm curious how hard those will get
sure all right so we're back at the tail
let me go ahead and mark some dudes so
this package it's probably not gonna be
in the same spot this time it looks like
it is okay but the tooltips said that it
gets randomized right and I have seen it
in other locations all right oh no that
I okay
Jesus I don't know how that guy did not
see me he was standing right by the UH
he's right by that door Oh someone
spotted us Oh someone definitely spotted
us yeah it's go time all right let's do
this
all right why don't you come up here
with me yeah probably make your lives a
bit easier are you gonna rock it like
Luigi get his rocket launcher oh man I'm
getting shot head up to where I'm at yep
can get that rocket launcher it's up top
if you wanna grab the package this time
you're more than welcome to sure let me
just say there's a goal who's about to
come up behind you then say okay let me
let me get up first the higher grants yo
man I got basically an mg and then I can
wingsuit up top and leave you behind
very nice the guy with the rocket it's
right here here's the rocket launcher
you should totally pick that up oh that
one okay yeah I think I picked up
another one let me grab this one it is
not giving me the option I see you looks
like you're holding it no no there's one
on the ground I grab me another one but
it's not a it doesn't want me having
this one unfortunately okay well let me
see if I can grab the UH you got the
package then and we'll get the countdown
timer going yeah this cold one right
here okay let's go
we could zipline right you can
definitely zipline and I can wingsuit
that's actually a good it's a good combo
so we're going to get it I did I did
okay we gotta wait for the location
here's a rocket liner here's a someone's
up here with us they might actually whoa
later dude oh boy
did you get him I did well he fell off
the edge is okay we gotta go back that
way
got it okay you want as if line out and
I will wingsuit and we'll meet up down
the road yeah let's do it
oh boy I am on fire from something I see
I see the numbers burning eyes applying
tight looks like I'm just gonna follow
after oh there is a vehicle here if you
can jump on I'm coming now
yep I'm getting shot I'm getting shot oh
boy oh yeah I got your back you did okay
cool okay so this time we are going to
escape by jet ski let me know when
you're on yo all right we're out of here
yeah I just totally stumbled on that jet
ski by chance and that was definitely a
crocodile I just went over there
actually worth a good amount stuck the
landing let's go ten out of ten Oh got
some enemies I just pulled out my face
like I was about to do some fish here
actually once you top on this mounted
weapon his your lower level but yeah
definitely do some work are you still
alive
don't be alive be dead
we're getting rocketed from so no that's
me I I'm definitely rocketing us here
see the mounted weapon works for you as
a lower level player sure uh where's the
mountain but oh my god no no no no
yeah I'm hiding smells like burnt bacon
boy or you could probably get in that
car and just run people over which car
there's they all pulled up in a car over
here oh yeah I can go around them okay
if you can distract them long enough all
I'll get in that car Oh someone's still
driving it can I hijack it
oh man see if I can make the guy driving
it dead because that car seems amazing
it's like at a Mad Max yeah I'm like oh
man trying to I think he's nobody's out
now here so you're gonna get it if you
can drive around
and oh now I have to repair it and I can
repair it yeah okay there's someone on
the back of it too
hang on tight I see the amount of trade
you're talking about let me what's you
right now there's a helicopter in here
no but there's a guy who shot me and
then ran away so hey I got you with a
giant truck nice I mean you're gonna
have to resume first where's your body
uh kind of behind the bunker actually
right to your right and there's some
enemies over me as well nobody kills you
but me now leaving you behind
no go on without be nice here lady we
got to drive the truck to the helicopter
if it's 10 feet away yep let's do it
let's do it
get in get on the match again I am so
ready to not get on the mountain gonna
get me that's the copter you son of a B
no way is it oh my god yes
get away from my helicopter all right we
probably should actually get in it
before yeah the helicopters under attack
before it gets destroyed oh boy oh it's
all on fire everything is gone horribly
wrong
just get in switch seats please oh yeah
okay okay here you now that helicopters
you got a lot of health mission
accomplished
well it's bear oh is that a mutant bear
there's me in there oh my god stuffed
look at that beautiful sunset all right
so that was a government plane wreck an
expedition in Far Cry new Don I hope you
guys had fun we certainly did and for
more Far Cry New Dawn including a review
stay tuned of gamespot.com
you know what we should do we should
find that bear we should definitely not
end this video and go find that bad
let's do it yeah let's go here he comes
oh look he is that growing on them Wow
look at that bear he's a gold bear oh
man he's a he's a mean old gold bear
shooting from the side he's attacking
the truck flip the truck ha ha oh my God
look at this guy you go bear
do that there is putting in work he's
barely getting hurt
I'm like trying to shoot around him I
don't want to kill him he's my friend I
kind of really want whatever resource he
has though
when's the plane gonna land in about 30
seconds all right just take the bear
yeah I've taken him out all right buddy
you did your job oh my god oh my god
save yourself Aaron Oh No Oh No
okay the bear he's coming coming for me
I am unloading everything oh that this
mounted turret has look at that look at
that oh boy nope I'm down are you
I was looting the bear just take him out
and then come from Rebney bika that's
the first time I've seen a gold bear in
this game yeah clear Jess we got to go
bear
come grab you I thought maybe I could
hide in the carcass of the bear but it
didn't go well
[Laughter]
like revenant yeah Leo and revenant all
right well we got from this bear oh we
did I looted it monstrous bear skin and
some meat yummy bunch of monsters bare
skin worse all right get out one more -
oh he's got a shield yeah no I'm out
yeah yeah no yeah no every button from
the side still a little bit more well
that was awesome I've never seen a gold
bear before I haven't never seen a gold
bear do that that is incredible
very nice two points for ya boy got see
how much that gold bears worth so that's
so that's interesting yeah you know
using the using the bear to our
advantage there yeah we chose not to
kill the bear to let the bear do the
work he flipped a truck he flipped like
an 18-wheeler and then took the bear
skin
yep and his meat and we're gonna sell it
most likely